-I'm a little embarrassed
by this,
because
I think there are probably
a lot of people watching at home
who would say, like,
"You know,
you're not actually nailing it."
And, for the record,
I forgot to record our sound.
So it will get --
my audio will get better
about halfway through
this interview.
But are you proud
of how you've learned
to technically execute
your podcast,
considering that,
I'm assuming, like me,
you did not have
any of this training?
-No, 100%.
It was a major learning curve
getting
all the technology right,
like, having to have
the headphones into the computer
so I could hear
the other actors,
but one off, because
we didn't want it bleeding over,
forgetting to push "stop"
on record.
You know, definitely.
But that --
I mean, just the fact
that I actually had something
that I could work on
during the quarantine was...
-Yeah.
-...talk about, like,
a bonus gift.
This was something that was
set up at the end of last year,
so I was already planning
to do it.
I just didn't know
that I would be doing it
from my bathroom in Idaho.
-No. It is true.
I mean, it is such
a good fortune that you had.
And this is a podcast that
you're producing, as well.
And this -- we should say
this is "Dirty Diana."
It's available now.
And it is --
there is some mature content.
-Yes. There is.
-And you --
[ Laughs ]
And, now,
I will say that even --
like, I feel like
one of the first things
I was aware of, of you,
is that you have
this really iconic voice.
Like, is it fun
to use it in a way like this
that I'm assuming you --
have you ever done just straight
voice work like this before?
-I mean,
I've done some voice-overs,
but nothing like, you know --
what I remember
hearing people talk about.
"Oh, yeah, you know,
in the old days,
when they had the radio shows
and everyone
would gather around."
And...
And it was definitely
a really cool experience --
I mean, literally,
just like this,
acting out scenes with actors.
And I -- my -- you know,
I guess
I don't think of my voice
'cause like most people...
-Of course.
-...I can't stand
hearing myself speak.
But I'm glad that
whatever others see about it
works for this.
-This is --
Basically, you are --
not to give too much away
of the plot,
but you help women
record erotica.
Is that like a pretty decent
description of it?
-Yeah. So at the heart of it --
-It's very steamy.
I've listened --
I listened to an episode.
It's very steamy.
-I noticed that you just sat
back there, Seth,
a little like --
like a little closing off.
-I will say
I found it very titillating
and then a little bit less so
when I realized you filmed it
in a carpeted bathroom.
[ Laughs ]
-That takes --
Does that
take the sexiness away?
-It was a little bit --
When I pictured you on a tiny
couch in a carpeted bathroom,
it was a little bit less sexy,
but I'm sure for someone out
there, that made it more sexy.
-Well, the good news is it's
just all about our imaginations.
So you can change that picture.
[ Dog barking ]
And -- Sorry. Sorry.
-[ Laughs ]
Did somebody just get their eyes
on a giant tennis ball?
-Murple. Murps, no.
-This was -- That was --
I do want to clarify,
'cause we talked a little bit
ahead of time.
I feel like people
might watch and wonder
why you just said "Murps."
-Murps, yes.
-Your dog's name is Murple.
Yeah.
-They're all --
and the rest are all going crazy
in the other room.
I am hoping that's
not bleeding over into our...
-No. I -- Murple's
the first one we've heard, so...
-Okay.
-I mean, again,
I want to keep going back
to giving you credit
for figuring
how to record a podcast.
-Oh, yeah.
-I feel like
not a lot of people
have seven dogs in the house
when they're trying to record
a very erotic podcast.
[ Laughs ]
-Yep. It was quite amazing.
Imagine, like, having to do
these scenes, which --
not just the erotica part,
which is really trying
to open up the window of --
from the female gaze
and really, you know,
take you down into the stories
that, in particular,
are reflective
of a woman's fantasy.
We certainly know plenty
about men's.
And...
[ Chuckles ]
But this also is dealing
with a relationship
that's very fractured.
And, you know,
at the heart of this,
it's about a relationship
really being at its bottom
and making its way back.
But I'm sitting in
my little, tiny bathroom
with carpet...
-[ Laughs ]
-...and the giant
Joan of Arc statue
that's excellent for holding
the towels after they're wet.
-[ Laughs ]
-And then --
-That's -- What a -- What a --
What a great tribute
to Joan's sacrifice.
[ Both laugh ]
-She's looking out for me, Seth.
She's looking out for me.
-There you go.
-But I would have these scenes
where I'm -- we did where
it's in a therapist's office,
and we're, like,
screaming at each other.
And then we'd go
on our lunch break,
and I'd go out into the kitchen,
and there's everybody.
"Hey!"
[ Both laugh ]
So that's pretty cool.
-Well, it certainly --
the result -- it was worth
the hard work you put into it.
You also, again, I feel like
people must've been happy
to have finished
filming something
that can then be released now,
because, obviously,
so much work has been stopped.
So you have a show,
"Brave New World,"
on Peacock...
-I think it's --
-...coming out on Peacock.
-Yes. And it airs on the 15th,
I think?
I could be wrong.
-Yeah, tomorrow.
-But the 15th, and --
Which is really exciting --
I'm, you know,
a small piece of it.
I just did a little bit of it.
But I really think the show
is going to really capture
people's attention.
It's a -- you know,
it's an amazing book.
And to see it translated
into something
that I think
will be great entertainment
and certainly needed
new content for now.
-I could not agree
with you more.
I'm so excited to see it.
And it has just been delightful
talking to you.
Thank you so much for making
the time for us today.
-Thank you, Seth. Enjoy your,
uh, fireplace of stone.
-[ Laughing ] Yes.
Let us -- We'll both --
-I like your --
I like your man behind you, too,
your -- your -- your --
-Yes. We got a sea captain.
I'm very lucky that, you know,
again, you have to find --
you know, you try to find
interesting backgrounds
for these things.
And I'm very lucky that
my in-laws
are collectors of sea captains
and ships, tiny ships, so...
-Oh, I have a feeling that
I would get along really well
with your in-laws.
-Yeah, I think so, too,
especially, yeah, again,
that's far smaller
than a normal boat would be.
-Yep.
-Just like your couch.
-Exactly.
-Thank you so much.
We'll see you next time,
hopefully in person.
-Okay.